[Music]
think lightly of yourself and deeply of
the
world it is difficult to understand the
universe if you only study One
Planet perceive that which cannot be
seen with the
[Music]
eye today is victory over yourself of
yesterday tomorrow is your victory over
lesser
[Music]
men with your spirit open and
unconstricted look at things from a high
point of
[Music]
view do not regret what you have
done whatever the way the master of of
strategy will not appear
[Music]
quickly it may seem difficult at first
but all things are difficult at
first the way of the warrior is Resolute
acceptance of
death from one thing no 10,000
Things
as you get the Rhythm you discern how to
win it is bad for commanders and
Troopers to have likes and
[Music]
dislikes pragmatic thinking is
essential it is wrong to be inflexible
[Music]
both in fighting and in everyday life be
determined through staying
[Music]
calm do not let the enemy see your
spirit do nothing that is of no
[Music]
use you may abandon your own own body
but you must preserve your
[Music]
honor step by step walk the Thousand
Mile
Road develop intuitive judgment and
understanding for
[Music]
everything become acquainted with every
art
do not let yourself be guided by
feelings of lust or
love I live by choice not by
[Music]
chance do not let the body be dragged
Along by the mind or the mind be dragged
Along by the
body get Beyond love love and grief
exist for the good of
[Music]
man respect Buddha and the gods without
counting on their
[Music]
help you must understand that there is
more than one path to the top of the
mountain if you know the way broadly you
will see it in
everything
[Music]
if there isn't discipline How can there
be a true realization of an
ideal truth is not what you want it to
be it is what it is and you must Bend to
its power or live a
lie 1,000 days of lessons for discipline
10,000 Days days of lessons for
[Music]
Mastery in battle if you make your
opponent Flinch you have already
[Music]
won you can only fight the way you
practice if you do not control the enemy
the enemy will control
you
the important thing in strategy is to
suppress the enemy's useful actions but
allow his useless
[Music]
actions the only reason a warrior is
alive is to fight and the only reason a
warrior fights is to
win to become the enemy see yourself as
the enemy of the enemy
know your enemy know his
sword when your opponent is hurrying
recklessly you must act contrarily and
keep calm you must not be influenced by
the
[Music]
opponent one must make the warrior walk
his everyday
walk
[Music]
in strategy it is important to see
distant things as if they were close and
to take a distant view of close
things in strategy it is necessary to
treat training as part of normal life
with your spirit
unchanging the purpose of today's
training is to defeat yesterday's
[Music]
understanding study strategy over the
years and achieve the spirit of the
warrior the path that leads to truth is
littered with the bodies of the
ignorant you win Battles by knowing the
enemy's timing and by using timing that
the enemy does not
[Music]
anticipate in time all things work to
your advantage when you pursue them with
an open
heart if you do not look at things on a
large scale it will be difficult to
master
[Music]
strategy
even if a man has no natural ability he
can be a
[Music]
warrior there are many ways of
understanding simple ideas but generally
the opposite is true of difficult ideas
[Music]
when you attack the enemy your spirit
must go to the extent of pulling the
stakes out of the wall and using them as
Spears and Hal
Birds it is bad to repeat the same thing
several times when fighting the
[Music]
enemy do not collect weapons or practice
with weapons beyond what is
useful no man is Invincible therefore no
man can fully understand that which
would make him
[Music]
Invincible polish your wisdom learn
public Justice distinguish between good
and evil study the ways of different
Arts one by
one it is better to be a warrior in a
garden than to be a gardener in a
[Music]
war of course the void does not exist by
knowing what does exist you can know
that which does not exist that is the
void if you are not progressing along
the true way a slight twist in the mind
can become a major twist this must be
pondered
[Music]
well what is essential is to think that
anything you are doing may be eliminated
you must examine this
well the warrior is the two-fold way of
pen and sword and he should have a taste
for
both all men are the the same except for
their belief in their own selves
regardless of what others may think of
them a man cannot understand the art he
is studying if he only looks for the end
result without taking the time to delve
deeply into the reasoning behind the
study it is difficult to realize the
true way just through sword fencing know
the smallest things and the biggest
things the shallowest things and the
deepest
[Music]
things